no vaya
e
[Música]
me llamo joey trabajo en el sector de la
moda y en realidad crecí en un pequeño
pueblo agrícola de arizona y me gustan
las artes visuales en la estética visual
la moda el cine todo eso así que si
podemos compartir algunos intereses
sería genial
esto es más extraño de lo que pensé todo
esto es puedo puedo tocarte claro lo
siento tienes todos tus tatuajes en un
estilo de arte similar este es muy
genial lo siento te estoy dando la
vuelta al brazo me gusta mucho este
naranja y este se está hoja ya está
justo al lado del corazón no necesitaba
torcerle el brazo así si está justo ahí
qué puntuación le darías a este brazo
del 1 al 10 a un 91 de los mejores
brazos que no hay en el seguro
otro brazo tienes dos estilos de arte
diferentes en el uno es como estas
grandes y coloridas flores y los peces
koi esas cosas y luego es algo pequeño
pero tiene estos números y cosas
otro brazo puedo tocar tu brazo genial
por alguna razón estoy recibiendo
vibraciones de videojuegos de esta
persona pero sí no tatuajes muy buenos
un siete y medio
a una pierna bien así que cosas de la
cultura pop eso es genial puedo tocar tu
pierna en sí bien genial a ella le
gustan las películas de terror yo soy el
más gallina en cuanto a películas de
terror así que puede que no haya una
gran coincidencia de intereses y el aro
cuando tenía 15 y pasé como 10 años sin
ver otra de hecho me gustan mucho sus
tatuajes así que diría otra 9
tiene algo de influencia hindú así que
tal vez esto es una cosa cultural que es
muy genial nunca he visto unas uñas así
lo siento solo estoy mirando unas uñas
con sus cosas de diamantes bien tatuajes
es todo trabajo de líneas y puntos siete
y medio también
su tatuaje parece tener una estética
similar a la del terror de la vieja
escuela parece que tuvo una visión
coherente desde el principio tengo una
manga pero en realidad son seis tatuajes
aleatorios que tuve que pegar algún día
sería genial
sería un 9 si no es como si estuviera
calificando sus tatuajes para que puedan
decidir viejos si quisiera cambiar
podría tener un aspecto diferente para
las personas tienen muchos significados
detrás espero no haber insultado a nadie
así que creo que voy a tener que
eliminar a la concursante número 2 que
le gusta el color y las flores y esas
cosas hola hola soy así que
solo tus brazos y
estética gracias lo siento
[Música]
y
debe estar muy incómoda ahora mismo un
triste tatuaje de tofu y al lado de un
teléfono el tofu que fuma hierba ni
siquiera sabía que estaba fumando hierba
pero ahora en definitiva sí lo parece
bien así que si esto es un se lo que es
esto es ni siquiera voy a decir el
lenguaje equivocado que creo que es
ambos son hindi esta de aquí dice de er
y diván y traducido literalmente tu
amante hay una canción de bollywood que
crecí escuchando y quería conmemorar un
momento en el que estaba enamorada de
alguien de esa manera
qué es lo que te gusta tanto de la
estética tradicional americana
creo que refleja un estilo rudo este que
eso específicamente
vengo de un largo linaje de mujeres
latinas muy fuertes así que esa fue la
inspiración y también tiene un lunar
como mi madre así que me da ánimo cada
día cuando la miro
vaya eso es muy realista voy a decir
a pesar de que solo una orca la orca es
mi animal favorita no es
así y este poema es un poema de dylan
thomas no entra es totalmente en esa
noche quieta rabia rabia contra la
agonía de la luz plenamente en hacer
absolutamente todo lo que quieras hacer
en la vida y no detenerte
definitivamente tiene como un aspecto
religioso o cultura porque esto se
siente budista eres budista no no soy
judío interesante que te hizo hacerte
esto estaba no me inicié la
espiritualidad del budismo fue una de
las primeras fuentes que encontré y
tenía mucha belleza en ella y
simplemente me encanta la idea y el ave
el ave solo era linda tengo un montón de
eso pero fue tenía ningún estrés persona
alcazaba
no vaya
es tiburón
es mi película favorita los tiburones
son mi animal favorito todos nos morimos
por vivir y ese es otro tiburón este es
mi primer tatuaje me gusta mucho el de
tiburón está en un lugar muy bueno sobre
todo para las chicas
la número 2 será mi próxima eliminación
me gustan mucho sus tatuajes no es el
estilo de todos encantado de conocerte
nya es un placer
gracias gracias
me falta una más verdad creo que voy a
eliminar
[Música]
o la número 4
hola uno soy ya lisa encanto ser
conocerte alguna razón por la que éste
no fuera tu favorito honestamente y sé
que se supone que no debo juzgar
demasiado por ello simplemente parecía
que había muchas cosas aquí sí eso fue
un poco intimidante tal vez es pero por
lo demás se ven muy lindas
ronda tres conversaciones
pregunta específica para la número tres
es lo primero que pensé cuando subió la
cortina cuál es tu altura
algo así como un metro setenta y ocho
creo 180 eso me hace sentir que estoy
mintiendo sobre mi altura
he salido con reyes cortos antes es
viejo ya odio eso oye a qué te dedicas y
cómo se perciben tus tatuajes soy
guionista de programas de televisión
para preescolares y comediante de stand
up supongo que a nadie le importa porque
casi parece que un niño me ha pintado
como garabatos y bueno soy una estilista
de mascotas a tiempo completo y de
competencias los baños les cortó el pelo
y las tiña qué tipo de competencia
básicamente hay competiciones de
peluquería en todo el mundo hay
diferentes equipos para cada país y
vamos de un lado al otro y competimos en
hacer corte este espectáculo en las
mascotas soy gerente en una tienda café
de tatuajes así que a los dueños se le
parece muy bien si parece que estarían
bastante tranquilos al respecto gente
que tiene tatuajes
supongo que mi siguiente pregunta es
cuál es el tatuaje menos favorito que
tienes ya has pensado es intentar te lo
cubrirlo creo que mi tatuaje menos
favorito es el ojo que por cierto es el
tatuaje favorito de mucha gente en mí no
lo odio y no me lo voy a quitar pero no
me gusta el lugar me gustaría poder
poner otra cosa ahí mi tatuaje menos
favorito es uno que no viste en la parte
posterior de mi pierna mi tatuaje de
disney no lo odio y no quiero en
absoluto cubrirlo o cambiarlo es solo
que desearía no haberme lo he hecho
porque por mucho que cada uno de mis
tatuajes signifique algo para mí esto es
un tatuaje de disney y yo soy lo
contrario de que película de disney es
de la dama hierba común 22 y
el mío también es un tanga
hay un poco grande tenía 19 años y se
suponía que era una especie de barco
pirata como una interpretación de ariel
como las sirenas que están al frente de
los barcos y yo era demasiado joven para
decir en realidad no quiero eso y no me
gustan estos colores y no me este
tatuaje me debatía en quitarlo pero creo
que sería muy costoso que
es lo que la gente se equivoca con
respecto a ti basándose sólo en tu
experiencia si estoy con gente joven
tiendo a obtener una reacción bastante
positiva y la gente ni siquiera me mira
pero todavía tengo que lidiar con las
generaciones mayores que me miran y mira
mi cara y son como oh bien y luego mira
mis brazos y mi cuerpo y dicen oh bien
obviamente no lo aprueban como
comediante de esta noche estoy en muchos
espacios muy masculinos y muchas veces
cuando estoy a punto de actuar alguien
siempre me pregunta a quién has venido a
apoyar de quién eres novia porque es
imposible que tengas este aspecto y
además sea divertida yo soy de virginia
y durante un tiempo yo llevaba un corte
de cabello roquero y los tatuajes allí y
decían esta chica gótica dominante no
debería estar aquí y yo decía en
realidad sí como me gustan los conejitos
y en los facebook cada vez que voy a
casa mi pequeño pueblo en arizona un
vecino llama diciendo que un sujeto con
barba y un perro estaban en la calle y
era yo estaba caminando por la calle
paseando al perro así que
definitivamente puedo entender t
[Música]
creo que la primera eliminación será la
de
la concursante número uno
es bueno ver el fenómeno
no se trataba tanto de ella me gustaron
mucho sus respuestas y creo que su
carrera es muy genial más bien sólo
pensé que sus respuestas no estaban en
línea con lo que estaba buscando sí muy
bien
creo que la próxima que eliminaré
[Música]
la 1
fue difícil
hola
gusto en conocerlos y siento mis manos
extranjeras mejor te abrazo de nuevo no
fue nada que ellos
encarnan anotó gracias lo aprecio mucho
gusta
[Música]
me acabo de dar cuenta que elegí a la
persona que dijo que iba a ser un rey
corto
estoy sorprendida
estamos en una pendiente
bien que deberíamos perder
pero si me encantaron sus tatuajes y sus
historias gracias sólo la atención
detrás de ella a pesar de que algunas de
las cosas eran como un poco más al azar
de lo que pensé cuando pensé en venir
solo parecías muy sincera y me gustó
mucho gracias sí es un tema de gatos y
tú decías todo está condicionado y yo
decía sí sí me encantaría verte de nuevo
fuera de las cámaras eso sería genial
genial
de alguna manera el verlo fue mucho
menos incómodo que me olvide de eso sí
ese es el que yo estaba como no voy a
preguntarte si puedo tocarla así que fue
la mejor y el tatuaje de kanye west esto
es diezmaban se confunde mucho con
disneyland zombie george washington mi
tatuaje menos favorito es el estúpido
tipo de villano con sombrero de copa
todo el mundo se ríe y debería serlo lo
respeto totalmente
terrible